when we finally do get a new Stargate
series there are five big questions they
have to answer
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
now there was that one episode where the
mirror Mitchell told himself that when
it happens cut the green wire the
Stargate never actually answered we
don't know what green wire that was we
don't know why he had to cut it but
that was a little thing and we're gonna
possibly come back to sort of loose ends
that Stargate left us another time but
for now when a new Stargate series does
come they have to answer the big
questions right I know I've had a think
about it and this is my list of the five
biggest questions they must answer in at
number five Is the destiny what the hell
was she doing out there what was this
fragmented message she was looking for
the Ancients made a discovery
they found evidence of a structure
buried deep within the background
radiation they believed that at one time
the structure had genuine complexity so
we know from the series of SGU that Rush
told us that there was this mysterious
signal message discovered by the
Ancients hidden in the background
radiation of the universe if you don't
know that's the background radiation
caused by the Big Bang or the big
expanse or whatever they're like calling
it nowadays and it's this just crackly
radiation that fills the entire universe
now he said that the Ancients found this
message but it was fragmented throughout
the Universe and the destiny needed to
travel along this path picking up
information as it went to try and figure
out what the message said we're talking
about a mystery rooted in the foundation
of reality
a puzzle with pieces scattered across
the lantern branch of the universe
itself now we have to assume that when
the Ancients ascended they found out
what the message was all by themselves
because well they were ascended but we
never got to find out but not just what
the message was who sent it if you
haven't subscribed already please do and
like and share the video wherever the
hell you want also if you enjoy the
content and you want to support the
Channel please hit the join button also
we have our sister Channel Sidetrack
size where we do lots of little best
bits from the lives and lots of other
fun silly little videos so please go and
subscribe to sites
and number four where is Atlantis now so
obviously at the end of SGA we saw the
Atlantis somewhere in San Francisco Bay
Browning
welcome to work
[Music]
that's right we managed to activate the
cloak before we came in too close
this entire area is under Naval
quarantine oh this is where everyone
went huh
well 15 years has gone by since targeted
last extended so where is the Atlantis
now what Mysteries have we discovered
now it's on Earth and we've been able to
strip it apart and really send a lot of
Engineers throughout the city to find
out what is really in every single room
every single lab and every single part
of that mysterious City also did the
Atlantis end up going back into action
they could have sent it back to Pegasus
even though that's not an option I
believe the actual American Military
would even consider perhaps it did we
know from beta Canon then it went back
to fight The Wraith we know that Joseph
malozi has talked about plans for a
movie that was supposed to follow on
from the end of Atlantis where the
Atlantis would have gone back into
action but none of that is on Canon none
of that was on screen so what has really
happened to the Atlantis in the last 15
years and the number three really this I
really considered putting this one at
number one because in lots of ways it's
the biggest question to ask and that I
want answered desperately but did Jack
and Sam ever actually get together I
don't know what yeah I'm sorry to bother
you with this
but uh
see there's actually a very good reason
that I am bothering you with this and if
I don't tell you now I might never Jack
I looked everywhere I could not now we
know that because of military rules they
were never allowed to we had so many
brilliant scenes where Jack handed his
resignation and then the first thing he
does is grab Sam and give her the
smooches
handing you my resignation resigning
so I can do this
[Music]
what are you smiling at
nothing
and obviously this was the ultimate will
they won't they I mean start off modern
schooling when you guys got together it
was boring as hell I was just like oh
I'll load it in bed together if these
two ended up getting together I'm
genuinely getting a cake I'm throwing a
little bit of a party it would actually
give me an emotional response
probably more than it should and I would
love for that question to be answered
now the problem is I think particularly
if Brad Wright had got his way Samantha
Carter will be in the new Stargate
series and she will now be a general in
which case they won't have got together
but at least it'll be nice to know
number two Jonathan O'Neill okay so we
know that the Asgardian Loki you naughty
little man did a little bit of an
experiment and tried to genetically
clone Jack O'Neill and then stole the
Jack and while doing some experiments
and tested on him and things
[Music]
hello
do not be afraid
[Music]
now in that episode when Jonathan
O'Neill came through the gate everybody
thought that he'd been some sort of
now in that episode when Jonathan
O'Neill came through the gate we thought
it was a young Jack we thought that
somehow he'd been made younger again
like in that one Star Trek episode that
was really bad all right hey
tell you what's wrong
I just woke up haven't had coffee let
alone a pee in seven days and I find out
you stole my ass and made a
mini me it was a clone that actually was
starting to degrade because they asked
Guardians knowing that somebody might
come and try to clone Jack apparently
put some safeguards in place so they
couldn't be and Jonathan little baby
Jack was about to die but hey
Thor swooped in last second and saved
the day I apologize for not coming
sooner
Loki what have you done yeah it seems
he's been playing Dr Moreau behind your
back
yes Dr Moreau
now the last time in Canon we see um
little Jonathan Jack O'Neill he was
going to high school and it was decided
between younger Jack and alderjack that
it would just be very weird if they got
to see each other regularly or kept in
touch now there was a couple of novels
that followed the series ending where we
did get to see Jonathan O'Neill again
but again they're not really Canon so in
the new series I'd love to find out what
Jonathan Jack O'Neill has been doing for
the last 15 years and maybe could he
join the SGC but the number one thing
they have to explain and have to tell us
about is the feelings now this was
always throughout Stargate sg1 sgusga
this was always the thing that sort of
bugged me the most they were one of the
big four races now we got to see The
Knocks not enough for me but we got to
see them several times really Armin
shimmerman is brilliant and everything
in and he was even brilliant as an ox
and we're watching Buffy the Vampire
Slayer again recently and he's the
principal in that in the first few
series
you wish time would stop so that you
could live them over and over again
you're expelled
um and he's Brilliance in that he's the
most dislikable character I'm just
absolutely love him
um and obviously as quark and all the
other characters who play in Star Trek
God love him
um but we got to see the Knox a fair bit
we got to see obviously they asked
Guardians loads and through flashbacks
and things we've got to see the Ancients
but we never even got to find out what
happened to the furlings it was hinted a
few times but we never actually got to
know we don't know if they've ascended
we don't know if they died out we don't
know if they just left our galaxy we
just don't know we don't even know what
they look like
um obviously Jack had his opinion on
what they looked like
what's up I thought I could make it work
the thermodynamic Loop is feeding back
into the planet's core
the Lee walks but we don't know now
there was a couple of episodes where a
mysterious alien race appeared and we
don't really know who they were we know
from things like a couple of the games
and a couple of other beta kind of
things that they were supposed to be
like a shape-shifting or a
multi-dimensional being
but nothing in Canon so for me the
number one thing any new series must
answer is what the hell are the furlings
and where the hell are they but actually
if you are a regular soundtrack even
though I'm doing a little bit of a fan
fiction series I'm looking back season
five now and in my new series of
Stargate the feelings would be the bad
guy I think they're just a perfect
opportunity the biggest mystery from sg1
the biggest unanswered question from sg1
let's bring them back into the new
series if you want to hook to really
bring Gators back into this new series
just tease us with the feelings oh it'll
work I'll be watching it just to find
out what's going on with those and at
some point if they are so a
multi-dimensional or some sort of
shape-shifting being please God turn
them into the evil Ewoks at some point
because that'll just be great so guys
get into the comments what have I missed
what out of Stargate sg1 sgusj a other
big questions you desperately want
answered what did they tease us with and
never follow through I'd love to know
get in the comments if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe click
that Bell notification really have to
thank also if you enjoy the content and
you want to support the Channel please
hit the join button and become a fully
fledged side tracker as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]